-Chance, why don't you
come on up here,
and let's see
what challenge you get.
I know you got this.
-Alright.
-I know you got this.
-Just pull it?
-Yep. There you go, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright.
Musical Genre Challenge.
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-Alright.
You're gonna get a song title
and a completely different
musical genre.
And then you're gonna
have to sing that song
in that style.
-Alright.
-Let's see what you get.
Here we go.
Oh, alright, here we go.
It's gonna end with...
Hey! "Hot in Herre."
-Country rock? [ Laughs ]
-Alright, so --
Alright, so, wait.
So, you have to sing
"Hot in Herre" by Nelly,
but in a country rock version.
Adam, can you guys figure out
some type of country...
-Let's figure it out.
One...
-Why don't you get
over there, bud?
[ Guitar music playing ]
Good luck, Chance.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Southern accent ]
♪ Wanna little bit of ah, ah ♪
♪ With a little bit of ah, ah ♪
♪ Need a little bit of ah, ah ♪
♪ With a sprinkle
of the ah, ah ♪
♪ I was like, good gracious,
ass is bodacious ♪
♪ Flirtatious,
tryna show patience ♪
♪ Lookin' for the right time
to shoot my steez ♪
to flash them keys ♪
♪ Then I'm leavin',
please believe in, ha ♪
♪ Yeah, me and the rest
of my heathens ♪
♪ Got it locked up
at the top of the Four Seasons ♪
♪ Penthouse, rooftop,
birds I'm feedin' ♪
♪ No deceivin',
nothin' up my sleeve and ♪
♪ No teasin', I need you to ♪
♪ Get up, up
on the dance floor ♪
♪ Give that man
what he askin' for ♪
♪ 'Cause I feel like
bustin' loose ♪
♪ I feel like touchin' you ♪
♪ Ah, yeah ♪
♪ Can't nobody stop the juice ♪
♪ So baby, tell me,
what's the use? ♪
♪ I said ♪
♪ It's gettin' hot in here ♪
♪ So take off all your clothes ♪
♪ I am gettin' so hot ♪
♪ I wanna take my clothes ♪
Sing it with me!
♪ It's gettin' hot in here ♪
♪ So take off all your clothes ♪
♪ I am gettin' so ♪
♪ I wanna take my clothes off ♪
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
That is...
Never, never...
Never in my life!
Never in my life did I think
that was gonna work.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Country? It works!
-Never in my life did I think
that was going to work.
But it did.
-Yeah.
-Wow! I love that!